[ Up-tempo music plays ]
-Hey, everybody.
Welcome to "Corrections"
for the week of May 10th.
Hopefully, you notice
we have a new title card.
It used to say
"Digital Exclusive,"
and now it says
"Online Exclusive,"
because many of you pointed ou
that all TV is digital now
and that when we called it
a digital exclusive,
it ruined it for you.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, last week, we said
I told you
that Shoemaker wanted it
to be under 10 minutes,
and it was 9 minutes
and 59 seconds.
-Yeah.
-[ Chuckles ]
-And that was not chance.
I have an incredible
industry-known internal clock.
[ Laughter ]
I can, without
looking at a watch,
I know exactly how long
things are taking.
And to prove it,
at the start of "Corrections,"
Shoemaker and I
have already talked.
I'm going to do it tonight
in under [Dubbed] 11:28.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
So, we will see how I do.
Okay, let's
get to the corrections.
We had a cockroach
smoking a cigarette.
It was a Marlboro Light.
Somebody who said
they used to be a smoker
said, "That filter is wrong.
That's not a Marlboro Light.
Someone else said, "If you eve
do a cockroach smoking again
the cigarette should not b
in their mouth.
Um, it should be on the side
or near the rear
of their abdomen,
because cockroaches
do not breathe
through their mouth."
[ Laughter ]
"They breathe through
tiny holes called spiracles.
So, that -- And I just think
that speaks to the diversity
of who's watching this show.
[ Laughter ]
That we -- You know,
it's not just, like --
We're not in a bubble here
We have all walks of life.
We have former smokers.
[ Laughter ]
We have cockroach enthusiasts.
And you know, let me
just say "thank you,"
'cause nobody's wasting my tim
giving me some correction like
"Cockroaches don't talk,"
'cause you understand...
[ Laughter ]
...that's not what this is for
'cause once
we crossed that line...
I talk about how
another misnomer is
that this is exclusive
in any way, shape, or form
And I said, it's not like
any of you
had to do two-party verification
to be here.
A lot of people said
it's actually called
two-factor verification.
I should clarify,
I use something
called two-party verificatio
in my social life,
which is, I will not
have a person --
will not invite a person
to a party in my home
unless I can verify
that they have behaved wel
at two other parties.
[ Laughter ]
I'll call up somebody,
and they'll be like, "Oh, no
he was great, and
he's really good at charades."
That's one, but if
I call up somebody else,
and they say, "Oh,
he destroyed the bathroom,
you're out.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, so, this was
last night's "Closer Look.
We had a New York City
parking sign
that ended with "psych."
You know, like,
the fooled-you "psych."
We spelled it P-S-Y-C-H.
And a lot of people said,
"It is spelled S-I-K-E."
And to everyone who wrote,
I just wanted to say,
[German accent] Do you realize
you fell into our trap?
[ Laughter ]
Do you know
that we put that in there
full well knowing that you had
all rushed to your computers -
[ Laughter ]
tap, tap, tap, tap, tap --
...thinking you are using
your own free will,
but we were the puppet masters
[ Laughter ]
You thought you caught us.
But we caught you.
[ Laughter ]
Or to put it another way,
psych.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] "Tumeric" -
I said "tumeric."
People said, "It's turmeric.
And then a lot of people said,
"They're both fine."
And they said that's an exampl
of elision --
or as I say, "a-lie-sion."
[ Laughter ]
This is a real burn on me.
A lot of people,
when they talked
about the January 6th
insurrection,
a couple of politicians --
I think,
Senator Chuck Schumer --
and we even showed the clip --
one time, said
"January 6th erection."
And then we, of course --
we made hay, as we do
when people misspeak.
And then yesterday I said
"January sex."
Who am I to judge?
Oh, I, um, talked about...
how I shared
a very personal story
about how, "My mom...
every night...
before dinner...
would make my brother and
drink a bottle of wine."
And then everyone,
even though that was
a personal moment --
I said --
"No less than 500 people
said it's actually
'my brother and me.'"
And then, this week, uh,
like 500 people said,
"It's no fewer than 500."
It's not "no less."
It's "no fewer."
So just people piling on.
[ Laughter ]
This is interesting.
Yesterday I said
I'd never been to Wyoming.
I have.
[ Laughter ]
I will say, that's the
definition of a victimless lie
[ Laughter ]
I mean, that's the whitest lie
you can tell,
is that, "I've never
been to Wyoming."
Snow White -- you guys,
we talked about Snow White
last week.
So, there was this whole ado
over at Fox News,
and they just ran with it
for the better part of a week.
"Is Snow White canceled?"
This was all based on one op-e
in a San Francisco newspaper
that was a review of
the new Snow White ride.
I went back and read it.
It's actually
a rave review of the ride.
It gives a lot of credit
to the people who designed it.
It said it's magical.
It said it's really good.
It pointed out,
the one thing that is odd is
that they added --
the old ride didn't have it --
they added a scene
where the prince
kisses sleeping Snow White
And they pointed out
that, uh, when a man --
uh, that a sleeping woman
cannot give consent.
You know, fair enough point.
But they didn't say, you know,
"Cancel Disneyland."
They said it was
a really good ride.
But then here's the proble
when you draw --
when you overdo it
and when you say,
"This is cancel culture."
Then, we started
digging in to it,
and one of the things
I pointed out is,
the guy -- the prince, you know,
he thought she was dead.
So it's worse than just,
"I'm gonna kiss a sleeping..."
[ Laughter ]
And then a lot of people -
and this is why
"Corrections" has value --
is I find out things.
Snow White -- You know
how old Snow White is?
14.
So, Fox News is like, "Oh!
We didn't get consent?
He kissed a dead 14-year-old
[ Laughter ]
I mean, this is like that thin
where someone admits to a crime,
hoping that you'll miss
the worse crimes.
[ Laughter ]
You know, he's with his lawyer
and the lawyer is like, "Prince,
you got to tell me everything,
'cause I think I can get you off
this consent charge."
And he's like, "No, that was it.
I just kissed -- let me think --
I was in the woods,
and, um, [Muttering].
And then, uh, there were lik
8 or -- I think it was 7 dwarfs.
And, um -- And there was, like
this, uh, dead 14-year-old gir
in a box."
He's like, "Whoa, whoa, whoa
whoa, whoa!"
[ Laughter ]
"She was dead?"
"I thought so.
The doctor said she --"
"Oh, good.
There was a doctor there?
"Well...it was a guy named Doc."
[ Laughter ]
"I don't think he had
a medical degree.
I think he was, like,
the only one with glasses.
[ Laughter ]
Um, oh...
Alright.
I was talking last week
about Mike Shoemaker,
our producer,
our taskmaster.
Talking about,
"He often will say to us
that he's not afraid of nobody."
-[ Chuckles ]
-And he will say, "I wasn'
afraid of Son of Sam,"
and he talks about
how he alway--
And this is him.
So you just, you know --
You think you're correcting me
but I was just quoting him
that he said, "I wasn't afraid
of Summer of Sam in 1976."
And a lot of people said,
"Summer of Sam was 1977."
So I was like, "Oh, great,
I'll go tell Shoemaker
that he's been wrong
about this forever,"
'cause he's always
talking about it.
So, I go up to Shoemaker,
I'm like, "Hey, Mike."
And he goes, "Who's that skin?!"
And you're like, "Why?"
[ Laughter ]
That's how he always talks
And he gets real close to you.
"Ooh, who's that skin?"
And he's wearing his mask.
And he, like -- He calls i
banging plastic,
'cause he cracks his...
[ Laughter ]
So, you're, like --
You've got a mask on
and a plastic sheet,
and his shield is
right up against yours.
Very, uh -- So, right away
you're, like --
You're just angry
you even, like, talked to him.
And I'm like, "Hey,
a lot of people
have been pointing out
that Summer of Sam was 1977,
and you're always talking
it's 1976."
And then, I swear to God,
he goes, "It was for me.
I was onto him in '76.
Everybody else said
it's Summer of Sam in 1977
but not Mikey the Shoe.
The minute the first body fell
I said, 'Serial killer.'"
[ Laughter ]
"I even went and tried
to tell the cops.
And Mikey the Shoe got no love
for law enforcement!
And I went in and I said, 'You
got a killer on your hands.'
And they said, 'Oh, Chief,
Mikey the Shoe is back.'"
[ Laughter ]
Um, what else?
Oh, I said --
I referred to the rapper Lil Jon
as Little Jon.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. I think part of that
is just me...
you know, worried, like,
that I don't think I sound right
when I say it.
But I just want to say,
I was, by no means --
I was not trying to belittle him
in any way.
[ Laughter ]
Um, I think we did great.
I do want to check on the time
uh, and see if I
got it right.
And as a reminder, I said
that it would be
[Dubbed] 11:28.
[ Normal voice ]
And we'll see how I did.